رابط تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط
دفاعاتها الجويه مسيره الاوكرانيه فوق
منطقه في مقاطعه موسكو وفي الجنوب روسي
اعلن عمده مدينه روستوف حاله التاهب
القصوى بعد تحطم مسيره الاوكرانيه في
المدينه اما في مقاطعه الروسيه فقد اعلنت
السلطات الاسقاط مسيره الاوكرانيه تسببت
شظاياها في اضرار مديح
من جانبه قال الجيش الاوكراني دفاعاته
الجويه اعترضت 25 مسيره روسيه من اصل 33
هجمه الاراضي الاوكرانيه الليله الماضيه
وقالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها
حققت تقدما على جبه زفروجيا في محوري
روبوتينو
ونوفو
وانها تتحسن في المناطق التي تمكنت من
استعادتها وقال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
بافلو كوفال تشوك ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تواصل تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه في محوري
سنتابع مزيدا من التفاصيل مع مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرامه الذي ينضم الينا من
زابولوجيا اذا
تصريحات والتصريحات مضاده اغلبها يتعلق
بالهجمات بالمسيرات ابرز ما لديك
بالفعل
والقياده العسكريه والسياسيه في اوكرانيا
تؤكد على ان الجيش الاوكراني ماض في هجومه
المضاد وان الجيش يسعى لتحقيق النصر
والعوده الى حدود الدوله الاوكرانيه كما
كانت عليه وقت انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
الوزير الدفاع الاوكراني الجديد
يقول بان هذا النصر يجب ان يتحقق وان
الجيش الاوكراني ماض في هذه الخطه
الهجوميه وبالتالي هنا في محور زبروجيا
حيث التقدم الملحوظ كما يبدو للقوات
الاوكرانيه هذه العمليه
العسكريه متواصله على اكثر من محور هنالك
المحور الجنوبي الشرقي لاقليم دومباس عند
بلده اوغلادار حيث يقول الجيش الاوكراني
بانه يتقدم في هذا المحور نحو محور
زبروجيا وهنالك محور اخر هو محور روبوتينو
وفيرب وفيه هذه البلده التي قال الجيش
الاوكراني بانه نجح بالسيطره عليها وهي
منطقه هامه جدا في تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه
نحو بلده توك ماك وهي ايضا بلده هامه على
محور ميلوتوبول هذه البلده الاستراتيجيه
التي يسعى الجيش الاوكراني من خلال هجومه
المضاد هنا في زبالوجيا بالسيطره عليها
على اعتبار انها عقده اتصالات وشبكه شبكه
مواصلات مهمه للامدادات الاوكرانيه فيما
اذا قطعت هذه الشبكه فان عمليا الجيش
الاوكراني قد يقطع الامدادات الروسيه التي
تصل الى شبه جزيره القرم وبالتالي هذه
البلده هامه بنسبه لهذا الهجوم الاوكراني
لكن عدا عن ذلك الهجمات متواصله ايضا على
الجبهه الشرقيه للبلاد تحديدا في اقليم
دومباس وزير او القياده الع الاوكرانيه
تحديدا قائد قوات سلاح البريه
الكسندرسكي يقول بان الوضع على الجبهه
الشرقيه صعب للغايه لكن القوات الاوكرانيه
ما زالت متمسكه في مواقعها بمعنى انه لا
يوجد هنالك انهيار لهذه الجبهه لا القوات
الاوكرانيه تستطيع ان تحقق اختراقا ما على
هذه الجبهه كما يبدو ان القوات الروسيه
ايضا لا تستطيع ان تحقق اختراقا ما بمعنى
احتلال المزيد من البلدات والتقدم نحو
مناطق في الدمباس وبالتالي المعارك
الدائره على هذا المحور باتت تشبه حرب
الاستنزاف بين القوات وهي تقبل تكبد
الطرفين كما يبدو خسائر فادحه بالارواح
والعتاد هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها ما زالت تصد هجمات للجيش الروسي على
محور افديفكا ومارينكا هذا المحور العصي
على القوات الروسيه منذ بدايه الحرب الروس
لم يتمكنوا من اختراق هذه المواقع وهذه
التحصينات الهائله للجيش الاوكراني في تلك
الموقع وايضا في لمن هنالك معارك شرسه
تدور راحاها الجيش الاوكراني يدافع عن هذه
المنطقه بشراسه لان سقوطها يعني سقوط
كراماتورز وسلافيانس في اقليم وكذلك هو
الحال في ضخمه تشهد ايضا معارك داريا لكن
الجيش الاوكراني يقول بانه حقق انجاز في
المحور الجنوبي لهذه الجزيره لاسكر شكرا